this is not some harmless hair
it's volcanic glass
and it could turn your life into an
itchy blistering experience
uh oh
it looks like today's forecast is
volcanic glass rain
how would glass get mixed up in the rain
what kind of damage could it do to your
body
and how would you adapt if this became
the new normal
this is what if and here's what would
happen if it rained volcanic glass
volcanic glass particles are thin
strands of glass fiber that form during
volcanic eruptions
they're known as pele's hair named after
the hawaiian goddess of fire and
volcanoes
the particles form when the wind spins
droplets of lava into long hair-like
strands
you know just like when you pull your
bubble gum apart
only these strands could be lethal
stretching up to two meters long
they're about
0.001 millimeter thick or just one
micron
that's about 100 times thinner than a
single strand of your hair
and they're brittle and sharp just like
a piece of glass
so grab your toughest umbrella because
you could get cut
you could be one of the 800 million
people who live within 100 kilometers of
an active volcano
or not either way you'd wake up from a
restful night of sleep to discover a
beautiful and mesmerizing light show
outside your bedroom window
you'd see the sun's rays glistening as
they reflect off clouds in the sky and
what appears to be a soft golden brown
mat of animal hair all over the ground
but don't run out barefoot just yet
pele's hair can end up several
kilometers from a volcanic eruption
but in this scenario it would be
everywhere
if you live in a place with frequent
rainfall like india denmark or singapore
you should consider packing up your
things
but where would you go
it would be raining volcanic glass all
over the planet
this spectacle would become a nuisance
driving in a rainstorm would be even
more difficult
you'd need to avoid using your
windshield wipers or you'd end up with
scratches all over your front window
and your car wouldn't be the only
concern
you should be careful about your health
and safety too
if pele's hair got into your skin
you'd end up with itchy red rashes i've
got little edge
and every piece would be so fragile that
it could break into even smaller pieces
as you try to remove it
if this volcanic rain got into your eyes
they'd become red and irritated
you'd want to wear goggles or safety
glasses whenever you went out in the
rain
but the biggest nightmare of all would
be the possibility the glass gets inside
your body
the most obvious way would be from
breathing it in
short-term exposure could leave you
coughing with itching in your lungs
and if the glass reached your lower
lungs it could make your existing
respiratory issues like asthma
worse
the one silver lining is you likely
wouldn't get cancer from this hairy rain
but you'd want to invest in a
comfortable mask with a good filter to
avoid inhaling the glass anyway
pele's hair could end up in your
drinking water
yeah the strands are so fine they can
bypass water filtration systems
this could cause damage to your throat
stomach and intestines
it could block your digestive process
and you'd need emergency surgery
and you wouldn't be the only living
creature to suffer
as glass piles up around the world
plenty of animals would ingest it too
if you heard cattle
you'd want to pay close attention to
what they're grazing on
or better yet come up with a method to
safely collect all of this glass
make sure to wear protection
stock up on field gloves thick sold
shoes and heavy duty umbrellas
but with all this material outside for
free
you could develop methods to reuse it
how about insulating material in
buildings
this would be a great alternative to
mineral wool that's used today
spinning molten rock materials creates
mineral wool but it's difficult to
recycle so collecting glass as it falls
from the sky would be a nice switch to a
more sustainable resource
but
life under the daily threat of pele's
hair raining down from the sky would be
more dangerous than pleasurable
getting caught by a surprise shower
would be like having a million sharp
needles flying at you
now at least it's not raining acid all
the time
no
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]